to take this grand finals that you guys
are about to watch this is a first to
three a reset is needed if you're coming
from the loser's side but if not
it's gonna go straight to melbourne i
don't know who's gonna take it bro
yo the chat is going crazy right now no
idea
right now
i trust chat okay i don't need to look
at it i know what's up
damn chat they make are they making some
noise though that's what i wanted
give me a one for melbourne give me a
two for new zealand if you really about
it let me see the numbers in the chat a
one for melbourne or two for new zealand
and big hooks coming in no barely any
damage being deal
oh damn i got a number
of the numbers
lots of tunes in there lots of ones
though
all right here we go grand finals
underway
there we go
the chat is [ __ ] down he's like
keeping him in check
make sure they put the predictions in as
well
i'm looking at them right now
oh yeah
okay a lot of a little bit of exposure
from yagami
wow just ducking into that evil intent
from natural
i have no idea
yeah this is a little bit interesting
but jen has moves to hit on the ground
bro so i'm pretty sure oh yeah
yeah yeah hey perfect round that's not
bad
all right let's see what that was the
beginning of the round to tell us
yeah that's the holding down yeah
oh probably just waiting right now
i like the respect though i will say
that i do like the respect though yeah
yeah
until we're verified on the situation
he's pad broke
yeah
bro that sucks because i'm gonna tell
you right now that ain't got nothing to
do with me i'ma just be real oh yeah
they ain't got nothing to do if you're
okay i'm gonna tell you right
i got out of this my hands are actually
clean from this i got no
i did nothing to do with this i didn't
say anything about the controller i
ain't got look the technical
difficulties they got nothing to do
with who you think is gonna win that
just sounds like
that's fate right there bro you might
you might be going into this
with a losing streak because the
controller decided to crap out but
that's fate that just means you really
need to want to win if you actually take
it back from this instance
damn uh this is this is actually i don't
think that's ever happened to me
from memory have you ever had like a
contr a pad breakdown nope like pads are
red they're like really yeah either it's
very rare and i've been playing i'm
telling you right now i've been playing
video games for a long time and it's
when it comes to tournament i've never i
have never
and i'm an arcade stick player so i've
always bought my own controller
and even if i did have to borrow
somebody else's arc i've it's never been
like boo like it's never like not worked
on so
yeah yeah but it does happen i think
that definitely happens
yeah i think the only case i can
remember is like when dion's fight stick
he has like those you know these top
level players how they have these like
frankenstein believers that don't even
tell you what components are in them yes
right proprietary switches and blah blah
blah and then like they go to the
tournament and it craps the bed and it's
only going up and then like hey petro
can you give me your stock done while
eva that works and now i'm like like no
here it is
look
you think i'll say no because i'm the
bad guy you know i'm the heel right now
but i'm telling you when you know we get
a different
top game bro it's the good cop
you know i always do that i'm gonna tell
you no so somebody else can tell you
yeah you know and it's just
but you're right though you're
definitely right though
but you know
you got to take care of your equipment
all you have to do i don't know having a
backup that's pretty tough that's hard
you know if you're at home you have like
five controls or something dude you know
i'm gonna tell you right now if the
controller crap out before the round
starts back up i'm gonna have a new
controller in like that's how many
controllers i have yeah and my now my
controllers historically don't crap out
on me with and i don't use anything
outside of a fighting arcade stick for
most of the stuff that i use oh yeah
yeah 100 yeah
and that's all right i'm lucky man yeah
it's okay
i'm assuming he'll be fine he'll have
something some solution
so
yeah
if this if you're actually a pad player
i'm gonna tell you right now right i
don't use pad that much for
uh anything but like even for my ps5
before i had my ps5 i had already an
extra controller and even though i don't
play fighting games on set controller if
i'm playing yeah yeah anything if i'm
playing elden ring when it drops if my
controller goes out in the middle of
that battle is gonna shut down a second
and i'm gonna have a literally i have it
on the box behind it's in a box behind
me so yeah yeah
dude i legit have like over there i've
got like ps2 controllers in their
plastic casing from greece like with
greek on it i've got two of them or
something because the other ones i got i
take i keep
like they're like 15 years old sitting
there but they're ready okay anything
happens in a little you know we're
playing like tekken 5 or something you
know on the ps2 hey we've got the
backups at all time you never skim down
on the backups no that's definitely
serious business dude i'm i was one of
those guys i tell people all the time
like i wish my friends that i like
played video games with growing up would
tell you like i was the dude who bought
the multi-tap i had the extra
controllers
i was the homie that gave you that extra
controller that you needed at the last
second bro but anyways we're back in
here this is a first step back in
business
awesome no reset yet for those who just
jumped in so they just started
yeah one round but yagami on winner's
side and then naturals on loser's
side oh down back four back to the pokes
and the power crush yeah you have to
backtick right there or you get a free
shoe shine
while standing for natural
playing the neutral
power you gotta
so natural has to win
two sets if he hopes to actually run
this back
oh not stepping trying to evade the
stance but
how to make a decision to go in on oh
shoeshine getting denied
breaks the stun on the counter hit right
there
yeah yeah
yeah because if you get the back four
two counter hit it put you in the stun
you have to hit forward to break it or
else they get a free launcher it's gin
[Music]
yeah bro i know you came all the way
from loser's side i know you traveled a
long way you said you came from another
continent that's good news bro but i
might send you back without losing
without me losing around i'm not trying
to lose i like it
i'm actually glad that
um yagami didn't get phased you know
because usually when you have a
technical malfunction that will throw
you off your game pretty bad like you
feel this pressure it's like i'm
screwing things up what's wrong
um and i was actually worried i'm like
this could be a big advantage for
natural
just because of like a mishap it's like
nothing technical
um but no like jagomi came back with a
vengeance and i'm like okay he's still
in it and it looks like natural's uh run
is gonna be really hard he has to be
he has to be getting his wins every time
he's gone he doesn't have unlimited
stamina he needs to just get it done
so to go back and forth pre-reset is
pretty tough no matter how you put it
let's see where they're gonna choose
yeah
yeah yeah
so let's see um if he's gonna pick a
stage that he prefers or i don't think
there's gonna be a character change to
be honest
yeah okay
my building oh running it back okay okay
still natural has to win the next two
games
at least all right it's going to be a
done deal already natural has fought
pretty long and hard to get back to this
point so i know he ain't trying to go
out like that but here we go
there we go trying to apply some
pressure but man you're gonna be just
ducking at all
four
on the float still gets the wall savage
axe for the end shout out to my bro mark
man
oh nice
they keeping that chip
wow
legit got over the down four right there
but wait a minute natural takes that
first round
natural trying to mess with his timing a
little bit trying to throw him off but a
good old denied again
[Music]
i think he let the second hit rip so
even though he committed to it that
means he would have been in trouble
spins the blue early yagami trying to
close out this round but natural a hit
devastating how like quick it is it
doesn't do much damage but god dammit
can end the round for you like it's
really crazy
there we go big jump knees
back to the low pulse natural got a
chance right now yeah yeah
there you go he's
he's got a pretty good low poke
i mean you're not stepping combo start a
4-4 counter head natural
combo power crush
spins the blue early that's good for
natural up 4-2 counter hit blocked the
lower
bounds
no he's going to use oh no the sprinkler
on the board for natural
oh wow so that was the wrong combo got
the wall actually got the wall bounce
but did the wrong combo thought that
elisa was right next to the wall ah
that that's that's devastating yeah that
could that can throw you off more than
the controller dying
yeah
oh yeah
see what the decision is going to be now
so that's one a piece right
one game back and forth back and forth
yeah yeah
so that means they're gonna throwing at
least you know getting some kind of
momentum is really good that way you can
potentially drag the games out you said
that natural was tired too right but
naturals been fighting naturally warmed
up fighting through this loser side
right and if you look at it
alisa
been kind of cooled off so now you can
turn up that offense a little bit see
how awake they are at the wheel you know
you gotta i feel like it's one of those
things where you do want to play safe
but you also got to see where the
openings are because they're just as
tired as you are
maybe even more yeah it's a double-edged
sword yeah yeah
okay infinite
wants that space i don't believe scenic
that's it
damn don't get in my way
oh fight
guess what he starts off gonna get in
your way
oh nice
nice oh
wait a minute
nice standard standard operation yo
triple roll
oh boy don't be spring kicking what are
you doing
oh wow a little bit off axis there
didn't get the hit with the chainsaw
yeah yeah rage wow
really wow
[Music]
damn he committed he committed
holding down back
wow nice magic guy he's swinging
had the hit but didn't believe
one two's simple pressure here to try to
start a bigger game
natural
with the life lead now
wow oh my god guys we're underneath
didn't get some massive punish for it
equal health really for what's
considered
wait really
it's not over yet we saw the rage come
back last time the while standing too
power crush works
okay okay but if you remember that's the
exact same thing that yagami did last
time and natural duck and launched it
nice keeping him in check naturals
always just one step ahead there you go
shutting down those chainsaws
hold two one four
okay
there's the hell sweep
how's it gonna approach it goes for the
stomp misses
okay finishes the two on four didn't get
anything from it this time the downfall
one's just a poke that game is adding up
natural
with the lead
yagami turns on the oh
challenges
yeah that was a good challenge that
plenty of health to take the risk
oh my god oh god no chill no chill
and natural playing like he's right in
yagami's living room
like he's knocking on the bedroom door
like hey what are you doing
oh wait a minute
very nice
reset yo we've seen that before actually
goes for the wild standing two gets the
hit oh watch out okay restart
opportunities the one we got three
didn't work down back four oh my god
they're back to one they don't watch
that
one actually gets through
one
match away from the reset natural
damn what are the votes
we have um
second where
okay so we've got
57 for natural for the re for the reset
but they're believing they're believing
so we've got 134 that's a lot of points
that's no joke damn
okay okay
let's see if it's going to play out
natural one game away from the reset
though
with the gym
and i think it's just because he's
not afraid to check in a lot of
instances down for ones the downforce
just to like keep stagger long enough
for you to be like all right what am i
gonna do next what happens next i really
like that coming from natural and
starting to even go further into that
gym move this we saw the one the 433
just to look for the block stun but we
also saw like the back dash so you can
tell that you know thinking about
playing a lot slower down the line
cool
now
it should be getting ready now so let's
see oh there it is boom
let's see what kind of adaptation we're
going to see i don't know
yeah i think that um yeah there's no
risk thank you god this is going
straight back at the same time i can't
really blame him
yeah because it's it feels like yeah
it feels like natural is really starting
to get like a feel for some of these
like for these games and it's just clean
in some instances if it keeps up this
way i'm not i would not be surprised by
a reset round one
yeah yeah yeah
it's definitely in a zone at this point
that very comfortable just playing the
same kind of pattern and look at that
wow that's tough that's tough
how's it gonna take his approach going
low you shine
he's zipping in nice nice push and pull
there wave a wave
oh yeah
okay
no
okay okay
i like that didn't commit all the way to
it
knows that natural is looking for it
counter hit down back four and once
again the same situation uses the blue
stuff catches them blinking and drops
the combo
oh my god natural on his way two more
rounds and we gotta reset
oh okay punishable
[Music]
trying to close the gap
kind of plays in a little pressure
trying to get out of yagami's range
they can get some sweet counter hit
action but kind of hard
because look man yagami's pushing and
pulling as well he's got especially the
chainsaws
so stressful once they're out
to not get buffed by him oh the
realignment
okay natural
behind in health but it looks like he's
got the the mental uh plus right now
you got me trying to slow this down now
your gummy trying to slow this down now
wow gets the counter hit on the one two
four there it is one round okay
okay
oh my god
and just the down four goes into
chainsaw mode
yeah he's giving him the chance to kind
of like hit himself and looking for whip
punishes you got me in trouble and
instantly all at the minute your gummy
has gotten rage always start to just
spin the blue stuff instantly
spring up spring back oh almost
good patience in the wake up
one three three there it is exactly what
i'm talking about starting to go further
into the moveless one round away from
the reset natural yes
oh nice i almost got a little reset
there no good power crush once again
natural slowing down the offense the
defense excuse me
starting the double knight
yeah
wow big lateral movements getting
serious amounts of damage
four four go ahead oh
talk about diamonds
in the oceania region and man natural
trying to get back
trying to make this interesting by
resetting the grand finals and now
yagami is on the ropes now we're back at
zero now it's the first to three wins
we'll be our champion here
we're getting a full length tournament
right now okay we're getting there
you'll get every bit of every bit of
matches we can pull out of this we're
getting it all we're getting the resets
now now is where it really matters i
wanna see how it's gonna play out
everybody's been has lost once okay
but only one guy can stay that way so
let's see how it's going to play out i'm
very interested i'm actually
really impressed not like it's
unexpected but like damn like it's some
serious as we discussed earlier like
natural went through so many people that
could have classified as grand finalists
and he's you said that he did what you
said then and then as you said like this
guy just got warmed up and put into a
zone instead of getting tired he's like
almost in a trance at this point where
he's like going just throw me another
match another match another match
i want to win give me another one but
it's two at least you beat two elizabeth
i don't care give me another one i want
the points
all three hundred we don't have anyone
yeah though this is very interesting
though the fact that natural is bringing
this back with the gin and it's it's i'm
it's very very like simple game plan
play like yo i'ma hit you with this one
two three if you swing i'm gonna get a
free down too you freeze up these down
back fours come out and natural just
really has a rhythm to his game right
now but you can slowly you can slowly
tell what's happening with elisa yagami
is learning what exactly jin is trying
to do in a lot of these instances
especially coming from natural and it's
slow adjustments happening but i feel
like if natural doesn't close us out
soon yagami might start getting wind of
what's happening
oh nice denied him
right so surprisingly enough this
pressure is doing good stuff
oh nice side stepping away it's actually
a launcher
okay change oh no wolf about now two
four could have been a lot worse
oh wow double lure sweet round two
fight
damn yagami's like cranked off the
intensity scale
the thing is though you can tell that
yagami
is kind of at wits end of some of these
situations because natural is just a
little more offensive right like he's
really taking it to him right now
four fourths through
the same game plan
gamepl
one two three one you swing on the three
the ones gonna juggle you get a free
tailspin off of that
trying to create an opportunity for
himself no good see nacho just keeps him
in check and then forces him to have to
actually block and he gets whacked with
the hell sweep almost every time
four four goes right down wow back to
the down back fours wait a minute yagami
with the red dress
using chainsaws go straight back to the
low like just about even slightly in
favor of natural right now oh my god
they're running to round four wow okay
okay okay
now you got me ahead now
four
lots of four four down back four
pressure and now you got me starting to
poke he's like you know what i'm not
gonna keep letting you get away with
just poking me with this up close game
get the while standing too
sidewalk and not be
a lot of these laws are connecting is
like
it's like yagami is like unwilling to
yield to start ducking because he can
get caught up in so many overheads
but it's just a mess like like how can
he maintain his game okay chainsaws
helps
ah just out of range better range
one more round left in his first match
of the reset
oh charging up doesn't give it a full
get sidestep
oh oh wow zips out of that one
let's get them in check doesn't the zen
stance no good
big big block right there
giving himself a serious combo oh okay
resets for the shoe shine goes to the
hop kick gets pulled that's it he gets
the first point he falls good ends good
there you go yagami taking the first
point of this reset of the grand finals
here in the second
online challenge for 2021 in oceania god
damn
back and forth back and forth
the hard kick to save it
but this is what i was talking about
though now you can see it's not that
natural is slowing down but you can
definitely tell that the understanding
of the you know the process the moves
that are being used they're really
starting to take its toll and now you
see a list of like oh i'm just going to
down jab i'm going to put a four here
yeah just taking away the poke game the
down fours the one two threes yeah are
not as pivotal now you're not seeing a
lot of four four you're not even seeing
the standing floors anymore and it's
because of the movement uh alyssa elisa
is playing at that range now but 4-4 is
a tool but if you're not getting that
he's going to walk around you and you're
seeing it happen a lot over and over now
it's up to natural to make an adjustment
if you really want to keep this lead if
you really want to keep that momentum or
get the momentum back right now you got
to stop
so let's see um i really doubt it's
going to change character honestly
he's like another guy that like
when things get a bit hairy he'll like
start considering that like you start
like saying maybe the character can fix
the situation
but i would say he should stick to it
and there he is good stuff going mishima
building trying to pin up um
yagami try and keep him into corners
provide the you know produce the wall is
another
scenario that you have to consider and
another level of pressure that gin is
really good with like sticking against
the wall he can really put your brain in
a blender so let's see if we can
turn the tables right now by providing
some walls
they've been doing so many infinite
stages lately this one this is like a
change of pace there you go big pressure
down four
and really and now you see the pace just
start to slow down now
offense get a little more visible for
yagami right now counter hit four four
uh just as i say that coming from a
natural in the gym
whilst black oh but the driver drops the
combo and a big change
right there
nice block
oh ducks
and look at this and now you see
naturals starting to readjust
break the oneplus 2
oh my god
this is oh my god
that jab is deadly oh my god and he's
like letting him remember it's like yeah
yeah yeah
but you see what i was talking about
though the down jab is really stopping
at up close pressure
natural in
trouble staggering the offense a little
bit blocks the low
oh big whiff okay minor punish
oh they are okay oh sweet that's pretty
good
okay this is a bit of a
stalemate over here oh my god not
anymore
man you guys could be your turn
[Music]
and it's really putting natural
in a bad situation he's really not
comfortable dealing with this pace to
listen
down 4-1 to stop that at pressure unless
the second hit rip wait a minute
what a duck okay wait a minute
oh man
this could be a tough spot
there's a splat okay standing forward
oh are you still in it he's still in it
he's still in it
okay natural getting himself his first
round
all right power crash this time no duck
oh
denial
definitely gonna get the wall now this
pressure right now for yagami has been
really strong while trying to cross up
low perry
wow
for natural 443 this time chase is the
special get up
he'll sweep wait a minute natural got
got some wheels got some traction now
down force the down four one try to go
for the down another one it's not gonna
work and harada cares
he's gonna pull charge no he does not
shoeshine
an absolute return come back this is
like the worst case scenario for natural
you know who cares how many horada cares
bro he had less than a fingernails worth
of life
harada cares
that five hp ain't gonna do nothing for
me i got a family i got kids to feed i
got tournaments to win what am i gonna
do with five extra points you better
talk to yagami yagami just did it you
made it count
with that five hp ain't wasting it on
slope he's dude he's putting that
strength of the s p 500 dude getting his
returns
damn
that's right straight to the s p 500
damn
that's crazy
um yeah man it's funny that today we've
seen a lot of these like you know
corrado steamies everywhere brandon some
matter but this one's the biggest one by
far
this one
are the murray stemmies now is that the
new is that the what's the matter who's
this is this now
it's still is still the harada care
right it's the harada care package
yeah if you have a harada let me see him
in the chat right now let me see your
harada's in the chat and we got taste
buds up this yeah stateside let me see
your harada's in the chat i dropped mine
off just to let y'all know it's real
but here we go
really
no i this is this is what naturals this
is the stage natural likes to go to to
get control of things but yeah it's not
working and it's 2-0 right now in this
reset after natural resetting
let's see it's kind of interesting how
uh yagami took control of this reset
with a 2-0 lead
let's see okay a lot of back and forth
taking turns
nice we've punished
beautiful carry nice high splat oh
damage
not much damage but if you can get it to
the wall create a better scenario for
yagami
oh my god yeah
challenging him with the rage driver
while standing forward low period
damn another robber it is insane this is
crazy i don't even know what's going on
anymore
he's two rounds away from taking this
whole thing man
four four
tries to side sidewalk it
gets around one of them wow four four
counting
dropping legs
big saws holding them back
okay y'all got me swallowing a bit let's
see oh using the armor
all deny that helps me finally there you
go
perfect response
tournament point right now for yagami
this could be it
natural still has a chance though fall
all the way through losers so it's not
over just yet not over just yet but now
you see yagami really taking his time
before going in really setting the
offense up with the jabs nice read right
there with the down four one four
yeah natural shouldn't be over extending
should be like be very careful with
decisions to end up but then again that
gives yagami a lot of opportunities to
come in with the chainsaws like we're
looking at right now
he's gonna put a stop to it oh my god
the damage
no chill
oh there it is there it is i had a
feeling baiting it and there it is
yagami
the champion of the tekken online
challenge 2021 for oceania masters event
300 points right to you guaranteeing
your position
into the regional finals in december
dude
very exciting and of course man one of
the maddest like losers run all the way
up into a reset by natural representing
new zealand and you know showing them
what the region's got very very good
performance very happy to see him back
with this gin which is something i
haven't seen in a while so a lot of fun